hello Gilbert today we're talking about
pal class yeah we watched that movie a
lot Harris just our Demerol hello here
we all are we all watch glasses don't
make some jokes about it live to tell
the tale
dan you're our honorary glass licker one
but not as a film I like it I even I
when I was rewatching it for this I was
like oh I wonder if I got caught up in
something when I was watching it and
then when I rewatched it'll be one of
those where you go like ooh what are you
thinking
nope no I like it I like it I think it's
um it's super weird
I get why other people don't like it but
I dig it I dig I dig what he did
I dig where it went I'm a defender of
glass I like the ideas behind it I like
the concept
I feel like Emma I sold the movie is
like alright it's about you know these
superheroes and like the meaning of what
it is and and rising above your human
potential and then bring out the best in
each other and other people trying to
squash it down they're like okay but how
are you gonna dramatize that he's like
no I'm just gonna have them talk about
it I'm just gonna have those things back
and forth I don't feel like it came
across in the plot or the characters it
was just the idea it was just idea
tennis like they're just betting the
ideas around the whole time okay yeah
when you say it's gonna be a grounded
superhero movie I feel like he got very
very focused on the grounded part and
forgot almost entirely about the
superhero part do you mean like what
were you expecting for the superhero
part because that's where a lot of
people see was like where was the
superhero in my superhero movies like
that's I think that's as much the
expectation game is what it's a movie
about that he's a superhero like
unbreakable already did the our super
powers real or not and I mean I think
this gets to my biggest problem with the
movie was it feels like retreading the
ideas from unbreakable rather than
taking it in like the next direction
like it's just
it's still just a bunch of character
sitting around like well this seems like
he's got superpowers then people be like
nah superpowers aren't real and it's
like that's the exact dynamic we already
saw an unbreakable but I bet it's the
differences we know this time that
they're real we know he's a superhero we
know beyond a shadow of a doubt
translate the dramatic stakes because
when she's trying to convince everybody
that they don't have superpowers I think
the movie wants you to think like oh
maybe they don't but no we've seen the
first two movies now yeah it just
doesn't pass the smell test that Bruce
Willis would ever doubt his own super
strength when he's been super strong
yeah I don't know I think it's more
convenient for him to not be a superhero
I think it makes things simpler for him
so I it was much more about about David
Dunn's struggle with this with this
thing like unbent press that benchpress
though like you've done it well yeah but
I like that it's a character P it's not
an action piece it's a character piece
of like they are trying to convince him
of this thing that he knows isn't true
but at the same time it's it is much
easier for this thing to be true and so
it's his struggle with that generally
and then mr. glass doing his thing and
the beast being the Beast and I'm like I
said it's some weird alchemy but I liked
it mmm I definitely think if you went
into this movie expecting like a big MCU
e-dawg or even even a 2000 x-men
throwdown of some sort at the end like
at your Liberty with like magneto you
know moving and monument yeah I was like
mm desk effects yeah we're like the
extent of the who is the beast running
on all fours if you wouldn't expecting
anything like that from the guy that
made unbreakable like that's definitely
not what you bet that's on you mm-hmm
you can do low-budget I think you action
I he's not gonna do big action though
but I I do agree that instead of like
showing his ideas and musings via story
everyone like sat around and like
chatted about them I almost was very mad
they're talking about comic-book
superheroes in their company I mean
they're beyond that they're practically
they're not
turning to camera there's no fourth wall
breaking but almost where Samuel Jackson
it sometimes is even calling out the
comic book tropes as they're happening
like characters are run out of the
asylum you'd like there are the good
friends and so it is very meta but it
almost feels like defining superheroes
out of existence like a lot of it is
like blurring the line between a person
who can just run really fast and a
superhero with top speed until that's
like well some people are just a little
bit better than others and so there are
no superpowers like what's the point I
guess the idea and it's like you're I'm
trying to be charitable it's like they
were the organization that's out to
crush superheroes
like this would be generation 1 because
like well when it started Superman
couldn't even fly he can only like lift
a car but it's so like these guys would
be like level 1 and then a twitch who
they need to squash but if they let
superheroes develop then they'd be like
dr. Manhattan hang all over the place
what the meaning that I took from it was
that there have always been people that
are capable of amazing and extraordinary
things and that in the in the world that
exists if they were if if unmask they
were to become aware of this then all of
a sudden you have a super race that
could very easily dominate and subjugate
ordinary people and so the idea more
super they all one of them just gets
shot whatever gets drowned in a puddle
that I didn't buy that they would ever
be a threat when they're just like doing
things like a an athlete well he was
shot because he had the weakness of they
found a boy they exploited the person
who could get to his humanity he is
invulnerable when he is the Beast that
you can't shoot with ease that is just
the base you can see skin is tougher
than like remember split all of split is
like his body actually undergoes
physiological changes so the idea is the
Beast has this really tough hide like an
animal and so you like a rhino or
something you'd shoot him and it doesn't
go through but when he goes back to
being just Kevin yeah you can shoot so
that was the bit with
you tale enjoy get her out there bring
out his humanity then take a shot at him
but but I sort of agree with what you
were saying like it's almost like a
semantic argument as a movie like well
what is superpowers versus just being a
very powerful non super person and at
some point like I don't really care
about that decisions I think in any of
that semantic stuff I thought it was
very clear that there are people that
have extraordinary abilities and that
there are people that don't and this
organization is there to find the people
that have them and try to as humanely as
possible
either convince them that they're not
right especially or deal with them and
other you only find that at the end for
most of the most the movie she's just
trying to convince him like well you
were able to bend those bars but that
great dream what's super nor is it so
that's most of the movie like at the end
that goes back and explains everything
but most a movie were just spending
having these semantic arguments about
what is superheroes versus what is just
being a very powerful man I just like I
don't really care that much I care about
when that organization practices their
their freeze when they're all eating at
the restaurant when the secret
organization is it like are they all on
encounter like one two three stump or is
it like when a certain queue happens
they all stop mid all right yeah yeah
you're a I'm sorry sorry guys let's talk
even more as we watching on this trailer
for I was gonna say split split glass
the unbreakable unbreakable mister
following trailer is rated s for
spoilers yeah
morning everybody that should
technically have watched yeah yeah you
from the director whose films make you
say ooh what's happening or what's
happening or just what was the happening
you like
right any excuse to play more happening
it comes this new film that will make
you say well that happened
glass in a world where Hollywood has
turned superheroes into a billion dollar
business and night is taking comic-book
movies back to their roots a series of
static images
all of that great spot I just want to
point out I don't know I don't think he
got into the trailer he's standing in a
comic book store in front of a big neon
sign that says villains be villains
section of the comic book store usually
villains are in the same books as the
you know that's a section I think it's
just ladies have signs yeah hey you know
what I think comic books have our
villain no he doesn't goes and he pulls
up a book about a villain and that's
where he gets the idea that's what
happens in that seems a very niche comic
shop but no they have another sign that
says dialog inking speech bubbles I just
want you to know what goes into comic
books anyways I love those villain
comedy yeah all the series of static
images is ever made of venom coming
that's a weird section you might have
venom section that's so grounded all of
the superheroes just lay on the ground
and die everyone dies in the park on
Easter comes to the inevitable a
sensation of cold water spreads through
his body your favorite break averse
characters are back like Bruce Willis
doing as little as you'd expect like an
Sam Jackson not doing much at all for
the first half I pause and I also
understand why that was to everything I
might illogically at odds with dishonest
trailers okay yeah I don't know Bruce at
the beginning I don't understand his
timeline first of all where it's like
unbreakable happens mm-hmm he's until
his wife Audrina until Audrey dies which
is how much after unbreakable 20 years
so five years before the action of blast
glass is when he started doing
superheroism I think he seems really not
into it forgot that's been doing it for
five years I thought he'd only been
doing it for like a couple weeks also
they seem so new at this well so the
papers haven't decided what to call him
yet five years you would think they
really would have settled
it's like overseer we're going with
overs yeah and the practical level like
Bruce was his superhero beat would just
be hokey but I don't think flies in 2019
it's a lotta unwanted touching man he
just seen if you pay for that cookie
yeah just a guy in a poncho like walking
down the street petty crimes I still
maintain I know we talked about the
maybe it was splitter or unbreakable
whatever trailer it was like what's his
crime threshold for touching is it like
jaywalking I think he do you like
shoplifting a hundred grand bar he'd see
it he would just decide not to do
anything you like
accidentally brushes against a lady and
he sees her throwing out other lunches
in the employee like broken I also think
it was not proportionate what he did to
those teenagers who were playing the
knockout game not cool somebody they
could kill somebody but that his kids
were reckless yeah they were reckless
but he definitely put that kid in the
hospital for well those kids put that
old man in the hospital it's more of
like an Old Testament I had this real
question I was about to get should
movies not feature things like the
knockout game which were hoaxes because
now it might be giving people it wasn't
in the unbreakable I didn't break
reverse its it was real they're getting
you're gonna have weightless salt bags
gonna have to ask the Momo movie all
right what it thinks I'm also at odds
with this two parts of this Dan just cuz
I love unbreakable so much so I don't
mind Bruce Willis in this movie because
he's just doing a disastrous plus extra
depression because his life sucks well
he's a sad sack real sad but I also feel
like there are ways that M Knight can
move that along a little better as a
director move this trailer longer hit it
Sam Jackson not doing much at all for
the first half
you've been getting that over room
allowed you get an mg customer but when
these three finally get together they'll
go toe-to-toe in scene after scene of
intense therapy can you tell me I really
know jack - I've come to the conclusion
like they're all kept mostly separately
on each other this is your MRI David you
treat people would think that comic book
actors or something I don't approve of
how they've handled you you can't
possibly explain everything away crying
was it our fault for expecting something
else from him night at this point cuz
this is a twist we probably should have
seen coming he will keep bringing me
back I don't want to be here together
they'll encounter the evil doctor stable
Oh mysterious we don't have powers and
she might be right cuz that's just
parkour that's PCB also PCP PCP that's a
lot of PCP and the super genius plan is
to post some YouTube videos even if they
trend everyone will think it's just a
viral campaign for muscle milk
[Laughter]
yeah I don't know i mean i think that
the it's a movie obviously most of the
things we talked about are that's the
idea that that that footage would like
the scales would fall from people's eyes
and they'd be like my god beautiful
truth finally his that doctor mr. glat
what do we call him they call him mr.
cohen mr. go thank you
this sort of cements my my opinion that
m night maybe didn't have the idea for
this movie back when he made unbreakable
but he had the idea for these ideas back
when he made unbreakable and they never
really evolved because a since
unbreakable deconstructed comic book
movies before we had any real huge comic
book movies except Dark Knight I think
we've now had like ten years of like MCU
and DC stuff for you to now have to like
look at and work into your
deconstruction of of the genre what you
didn't do but then also like the plot
twist of YouTube videos from like the
era of unbreakable like okay sure maybe
in 1999 if that video had popped up like
on your on your real player yes you
would have been like is is a superhero
real right and the kids in the beginning
where we're running around with like a
1999 they would be filming on their
phone just sided this did he put the
stuff in the beginning about viral
videos like salt Bay and those kids
filming their cells to plant the idea
that like culture has changed by viral
videos you guys like this video could
change everybody's perspective
talked a lot about views and like stuff
like that for you should just set it in
the late 90s or something yeah I don't
know if you're right if he wanted to
bring this movie into more the modern
era would have talked about like oh
phase 9 the hero turns on the villain
and they add a new alien like the it
didn't really respond to the current
comic book culture which is like these
insane film events I
in the struggle though because the
entire film was conceived unbreakable
was conceived in the late 90s yeah it
was like you said there were no cowboy
movies so mr. glass is not a is not a
villain who is versed in the
quote/unquote modern era of comic book
films and comic book the MCU and
everything else he knows like this is
our comics of the seventies and so it's
tough of your M night because it's like
mr. glass wouldn't know any of that
stuff so the world also big now haven't
changed like it actually doesn't make
sense in his references would be like
old school because that was the comics
that he read but but yeah like I just it
does feel like at a certain point that
it's so married to like well here's what
would happen next in a comic book here's
what would happen next in a comic book
then it just feels like this story
doesn't develop on its own terms it's
all just like well the next thing that
would happen in a comic book is ax
especially dr. staples club or group or
whatever like I get that we don't can't
find out about them until the twist
because I you say like this is what
would happen in a comic book I feel like
that was his point is that comic books
are tapping into this like cosmic
unconsciousness of these patterns that
we keep books are like your guide to
this real thing that happens
comic books are just our way of talking
about them yeah but to me the end of it
completely subverts that though and the
sense that you do think this whole thing
is leading up to this is what happens in
a comic book is you think it's going
toward this huge showdown at this to our
opening tower with the chemicals and in
the end it's not and that's sort of mr.
glasses pointed at the end was just like
you thought this whole thing was about
the big master is showdown the climax
between the villain and the hero you
thought this whole thing was about this
is what happens in a comic book is like
it's not or at least it's not in the way
that you thought it was what this has
all been about as an origin story this
is not the end this is the beginning
right no I know they that's what he's
that would have been a great movie if it
showed me that and like maybe I came to
that realization but it was literally
Sam Jackson is saying this is an origin
story you thought it was like this but
it's actually like this
all the people who are gonna realize
that like I'm a superhero but that's not
what origin story means in comic book it
means this is the creation of this hero
but inside to create billions of
slightly above average this this event
will lead to the awakening of an entire
generation of heroes so in that aspect
it is their origins that's a Preakness
that's not a lot of people to comment
fake and say is this for muscle milk but
it's movie like we said let's keep going
so suit up for the third chapter of a
trilogy that may not have stuck the
landing but at least it's an original
self-financed project from a true auteur
that doesn't feel like anything else in
an oversaturated market better with
another big cameo at the end they're all
great glass half not in the movie son of
a gun
Casey ex-girlfriend hi I'm dr. staple I
can't say doctor it's the the sketch
College yeah well Ferrell's character is
dr. Beeman yeah
dr. Beeman's office I think is what the
sketch is called and it's just a
absolute train wreck of an SNL sketch I
remember watching it live and thinking
it was the least funny thing I've ever
seen and now watching it in retrospect
performance in this sketch is incredible
the sketch the writing it makes no sense
but that Ferrell performance beautiful
and and in retrospect Chris Parnell for
not breaking yes whole world the whole
world is burning around him oh they're
gorgeous
golden
beautiful golden fur Tim Meadows walks
is is hi I'm dr. Stephen poop there's
nothing I could do about your song but I
can do the robot yeah yeah I don't know
what else to say except it's it's not an
inside joke it's it's a very deep
percent of one percent dr. staples what
do you do what do you do with it the
joke is that it says dumb as in
everybody up improv SNL sketch that went
off the rails but we have some alts
which we'll get to after this keep going
and James McAvoy nice and simple salt
day what is that anyway it's an internet
guy he's a butcher salt is meat in
elaborate way oh man I didn't realize
this takes place in the same universe is
salt bay with a twist
it's just that choice I see it's like
seeding the idea of like viral video
sounds like that but just make one up
because that one dates it to such a
specific time thing to me specifically
is that scene is the most emotion and
awakeness Bruce Willis shows and the
whole he's like what is that it like he
actually planters with his son in that
scene and they're not acting
[Laughter]
I'll get one of the stakes very glad
that kid from unbreakable and gladiator
its Spencer treat Clark man yeah that
blew my mind while I was I never made
that connection where that unbreakable
kid is also glad so when I looked him up
I was like of course now they said you
didn't like that moment at the end when
I went like the big reveal is happening
and people are finding out the
superheroes exist in the world and it
pushes it on his face and it flashes
back to that moment from them breakable
when he's sitting across the table from
his dad and he realizes he's a superhero
on his dad's it's like Shh and now he's
like living in this moment now where he
doesn't have to keep that secret anymore
I'm breakable it's a very same thing
Spencer treat Clark is actually good in
this and I did like that moment it's a
it's a good performance and he's doing a
good job of sort of like tying it back
to his previous performance at
unbreakable so I will give you that one
thank you I was still I mean that
brought me back to neutral but I was
still pretty low after Bruce Willis
drowned in a shelf like a slightly
stronger than average person the moment
that was so mystifying to me was when
the guy shoots James McAvoy and then you
the camera does this very specific pull
to show that he has a four leaf clover
tattoo but it doesn't mean anything to
us and breakable for published it rises
the clover Oh clover field over field
tie-in which would have been a lot
really throwing this for a loop but it's
part of the origin story the origin of
the clover field nights what a paradox
let's see some deleted scenes or just
start storing tryhard and Bruce a ball
die easily
Oracle
mother and may see your doctor pencil
doctor eraser stable yeah infinity
border and fitted each or never we were
back at Fort Lee worthy of magazine yeah
I mean okay Dan you're making a pretty
good case for why it's good I want to
see the movie that you're describing I'm
glad that it lives in my head and the
heads of uh there's literally dozens of
us yeah even in the even the way I'm
sure M night pitched it and he must be
really good pitching a movie because he
gets a lot of crap made it must have
been a good concept but then it for me
it's like the prequels it's like it
sounds interesting but then the
execution is just so plodding and
awkward and slow and then they pay for
it himself so he did you're right that's
the pitch wasn't that hard tonight it
really was just like and I'm like the
prequels maybe we need like a little bit
some notes from somebody that's not
that's cutting the check but I can stop
by the game of thrones said he couldn't
stop by I want to watch a George Lucas M
night collaboration that dialogue would
be incredible yep I don't like glass
that's you yes everywhere my god glass
is made of saying
[Applause]
all right that's Dan Merrill stop J
Gilbert Joestar lawn Merle or Allen
Harris that to us looks enough thank you
guys for watching we'll see you next
week for another Lucas oh yeah yeah so
chew on that and we'll see you later bye
[Music]
you